I'm so excited and I'm salivating,
I love food, I love eating, I skipped lunch,
so that I could tear through all of this stuff
and not because I'm on a diet, because I needed room.
I get it, I get it.
I was like I have to just make space.
What are we making?
We're making a Cubano, which is a very traditional-
(Drew gasps)
Yeah.
It's a very traditional recipe.
We're gonna do it in a tortilla, is that okay?
Yes.
Okay.
So I'm gonna show you a little fold hack that's fun.
So we're just gonna take this tortilla.
Now you can go like that if you want, just to warm it up,
that's how you do it, you just go like this in here.
There's like-
And what that does
is there's moisture in here, it just wakes it up.
Yeah.
You know?
And see, now it's warm, it's loose, right?
So you're just gonna cut down here like a little, that.
Okay, let me show everybody, that's it
and then we have four quadrants.
One, (laughs) one, two, three, four.
One, two, three, four, take your pick, go.
Okay, there's no race.
I'm sorry, everything is a race in the Food Network.
(audience laughing)
Good amount of mustard,
you really need mustard, okay?
I love mustard.
Okay, I'm gonna take the cheese with my hands, okay,
'cause I'm eating this and you need cheese,
I mean, cheese is everything on this sandwich.
Then the ham, what I like to do
is I like to just sort of fold a couple pieces like this,
one, two, okay.
Just a lot of ham, you won't put all that ham,
that's just for display.
But we're staying within the restricted boundaries
of the quadrants, okay.
Okay, boundaries, understood.
(audience laughing)
And then press a bit,
just a little bit, just a little smoosh
and then don't fold this one this way, fold it that way,
so the weight magnifies the pickleness of everything.
So we can just put a little touch of this, not too much
and there we go.
Now we did one, which is sad.
So if you put this in, you leave it a little too long,
it's okay, the cheese has to be like a cheese pull,
it has to be like that, so should we have a bite?
Yes, please.
Oh, look at that crisp.
Leave it, cook and it'll tell you when it's done,
it has a little signal.
I don't know why I'm making such a big deal
about picking the piece I want.
And if you don't like one of those,
you just pick another one. (laughs)
Okay? Oh, it's good.
Cheers.
Cheers. How nice.
(audience applauding)
Pouring rain.
What's so perfect about this sandwich
is the balance.
Mm-hm.
You've got the yummy pickle, the protein, the cheese.
It's so simple, that mustard is such a perfect kick.
You sound like a "Chopped" judge, did you notice?
She gave all those little taste points
and that was very good, I'm gonna have you on the show.
You have no idea.
(audience applauding)
What do you think about her as a "Chopped" judge, right?
It's hard to chop a kid though. (laughing)
If you chop a 12-year old's stuff.
My kids and I have seen almost every episode made
of "Chopped Junior," I've seen every episode of "Chopped."
I've been your biggest fan for so many years
Thank you so much.
and I've loved watching you.
We know you're like one of the world's greatest chefs,
but the way that you come across as we watch you,
I just love you as a human being so much as well.
That's very sweet, oh my gosh, thank you.
(audience applauding)
How's the sandwich? (laughing)
It's so good, I would go in for the third bite.
Go in there, I'm all done already, chefs eat fast.
Speaking of you on television, "Big Restaurant Bet."
"Big Restaurant Bet," it is 10 o'clock
on Food Network on Tuesday.
It's great, it's just everything.
Oh my God, look what I did.
I know, I probably did the same thing.
(audience laughing)
Does that happen to people?
Oh yeah.
Oh, yours is, you win, I lose.
I'm like and yet I would totally eat this.
I'm gonna make another one, "Big Restaurant Bet,"
we found eight of the best chefs in the country,
there are thousands, we found eight
and they all wanna have a restaurant,
their dream is to have a restaurant.
Which is so hard to do.
Oh, especially now.
And my wife and I, my wife runs our companies,
so my wife and I are the judges.
Such a family affair.
Yeah and it's funny,
because it was like roll the camera
and they put the food in front of us
and we just started talking like we do
and it was like, that's the show.
So, but we threw in all these terrible, terrible things,
that are gonna happen to you, 'cause they happened to us.
Someone walks out, someone burns something,
someone gets nasty in the dining room, the gas goes,
you know, all this stuff you gotta manage,
'cause now you're a chef, you're a great chef.
Now you're an owner, guess what that means?
We shovel you all the problems of the restaurant,
that you never knew existed.
Yes.
And the audience is gonna find out how really awfully hard
it is to actually open the restaurant.
The greatest chef in the world
doesn't mean it's gonna be successful.
I have to say nobody has ever shown what that journey is,
we've only heard how it's difficult,
but nobody knows how it functions
and nobody knows what it really looks like
and you're showing the seams and taking people
behind an industry that we are all dying to know
how it functions, bravo to you for this fresh concept.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
Seriously.
No, thank you,
because I think it's important.
It's a competition show, but but the prize is not glory,
the prize is the ascent of the glory,
maybe, if you do it right and so the winner
gets my wife and I to consult with them
and we give them all our resources, our time, our energy
and we help them watch out for the barbed wire,
watch out for the problems that are gonna happen.
Well, who better to-
Yeah, it's good.
Lead and give this privilege.
We've seen it all, we have seen it all.
(melodic upbeat music)